what does this mean really for google
and its perception right now given that
this is a google executive that may have
been killed by a prostitute so you know
he worked at Google he worked at Apple
he worked at son he worked at a lot of
the iconic American technology companies
she was 51 when he died seems to have
been mostly a hardware guy by background
you know it's a sensational and very sad
story right he was injected heroin we
don't know if it was willingly or
unwillingly he's a father of five kids
who's married for 17 years you know we
thought he's a guy with a middle-aged
corporate executive and I think if it
says anything it probably says something
about the fact that technology and
Silicon Valley are becoming like every
other huge mainstream part of the
American and global economy we have high
pressure executives who under pressure
under whatever family constraints they
may have nose and a few minutes extent
are behaving in ways that we may not be
proud of I don't think it says anything
specific about the behavior of Silicon
Valley I think in some ways this may
just be the maturation of Silicon Valley
to be as big a place with as many
dollars flowing as you have in the
traditional bad boy please adorable
Michael there's sort of this halo effect
around the Silicon Valley and around
tech execs whereas Wall Street has
really been vilified I mean you just
have to think of wolf of Wall Street to
get one example of that and you think
about all the the challenging times at
the wall street community has been
through as of late they're kind of easy
to hate Silicon Valley not so much and
then a story like this happens does it
change people's perception of the tech
community I think that's a very good
question you know in Silicon Valley we
do make things by one of the reasons
people like what we do is that we make
stuff we make stuff that didn't exist
before and might not exist without us
whereas in Wall Street though they do a
very important function it's easier to
hate them because they effectively move
money from left to right and from what
right to left it's a kind of a rent on
the global economy so easier to hate was
actually about actually making a product
on the other hand if this has anything
are going to tell you there's a halo
around Silicon Valley
there aren't words like me or executives
like him and guess what were people to
weekly are humans with foibles and
frailties and whether it's the pressures
of work or the pressures of being alive
or just being a human being which is
difficult enough as it is when you add
all of that cindy remix to a huge huge
amount of money slowing right this guy
was found on his 50-foot docks right
outside includes where he lives but this
is not a middle-class problem this is a
an executive high-pressure kind of
situation infinite back me how about
next year's you have SAT back sometime
yeah you know and look you know clearly
he made a lot of mistakes um you know as
you said a father of five yet you know
back to this issue contrasting Wall
Street with Silicon Valley and you think
even about pay for example and the
demonization of Wall Street pay where
you know tech execs are making equal if
not more money and yet it's not seen to
be quite as egregious does this get back
to the idea of you know something's
being built as opposed to you know a
derivatives product that is moving money
from one place to the other you know
you're asking me to answer in the stack
of virtues I think making things and
selling the things you make or making
things and giving you things away did
you make is somehow more virtuous than
shifting money left to right we need
both okay and so I don't think that we
need to vilify Wall Street and celebrate
over much or have a hagiography of oh
yeah you need those because Michael you
need Wall Street and Wall Street need
you